Let's check out some of the interesting discussions
on the David Pakman show. Read it The David
Pakman Show. Read it now has a we are within
striking distance. Let me put it that way.
Of twenty thousand subscribers, one of the
largest progressive independent media subreddits
out there. Go to David Pakman dot com slash.
Read it to find it. A user named Dismal Structure
posted some polling about how well Joe Biden
is doing in Arizona, Florida and Georgia.
Now, while it is true that there is one poll
that has Biden up, one in Georgia, but Biden
is on average down seven or eight points in
Georgia. I don't consider Georgia a battleground
state. I don't really consider it in play.
But that could change Arizona and Florida.
We've been talking about a lot and are really,
really important signals about how the November
election could go. But I just want to reiterate,
I have no problem looking at polls. I've no
problem reporting on polls to you. What I
am cautious of is I don't want anybody to
see a poll in their state that looks good
for Biden and to say Biden's got it in the
bag. I don't need to vote. So the reason I've
only been talking about these polls sparingly
is I'm trying to be responsible and avoid
any action that might suppress the vote by
getting someone to say, I don't need to go
out there and vote. So I will, of course,
tell you what the polling is looking like
and we've been doing it. I appreciate it being
posted to the subreddit, but we should consider
polling a possible snapshot today in May and
not representative of what is certain to happen
in November. And everybody's got to go out
and vote. Here's kind of a funny post from
Brody Mulligan. Brody says, Should we outlaw
endless shrimp, endless pasta and free refills?
The Corona virus disproportionately kills
people who are obese. People who are obese
are more likely to partake in endless shrimp,
endless pasta or free refills. We can use
public health justification to crack down.
Should we listen? Here's the thing. I when
I was like nine, I went to Ponderosa in Northampton,
Massachusetts, and would love just going up
to the buffet endlessly when I was 17. I once
went to an Olive Garden and they'll just keep
bringing you bread, strict breadsticks, if
that's what you want. It's obviously not a
good thing. We know from looking at the work
of food psychologists that it encourages overeating.
It causes overeating. I don't know if Brody
is literally serious about banning endless
shrimp and endless pasta. But one of the things
I think we have to consider is while I'm sure
Brody's instincts are coming from a very good
place, a lot of these things will disproportionately
hit poorer people. I would venture a guess
that folks more likely to patronize places
with a buffets or unlimited this or that are
disproportionately likely to be folks with
less money. And so in the same way that I
understand why we might say sixty three million
people voted for Trump, we need some kind
of a test in order to be allowed to vote.
That's the type of stuff that will disproportionately
hit poor people. It also, when it comes to
voting, I think would be unconstitutional.
So I get the instinct. BRODY But I think we
may end up causing new problems if we do that
and we want to bear that in mind. Lastly,
we talked about this on the bonus show this
week. Donald Trump keeps saying that there's
a cost to staying closed. For example, suicides
would go up. I've not yet seen data from the
United States about that. But what we know
in Japan is that suicides are actually down
as the lockdown has removed a lot of the stressors
associated with daily life. We know that commuting
to jobs is one of the most stressful and least
pleasant things for people to do. We know
that work culture is a very stressful anxiety
causing thing for people to do. And suicides
are down in Japan during the lockdown. Now,
it's important to mention the U.S. isn't Japan.
Japan is stereotypically known for a particularly
toxic work culture. I'm not saying the exact
same thing would happen in the U.S., but when
Trump offhandedly throws something out as
if it's an absolutely foregone conclusion,
suicides will be up if we're locked down.
There are, at least anecdotally, Americans
who are actually better off because they're
preferring to work from home. They have eliminated
a lot of scope, cultural stresses of being
at work, the commuting, etc. It needs to be
researched. And I'm sure you all know this.
Don't assume that because. Says something,
it's necessarily true. Join the discussion
on the subreddit at David Pakman dot com slash
r e d d i t.